it's been 20 years since the matrix
changed genre cinema forever and now
lana wachowski Keanu Reeves and
carrie-anne moss are returning for a
fourth film so we're taking a look at
some of the biggest questions we want
answered in the matrix for now that we
know Keanu Reeves is returning for more
of the matrix the big question is how
his character neo comes back after his
apparent death in the Matrix Revolutions
the Oracle suggests that we might see
him again at the end of the film will we
ever see him again I suspect so but his
body is carried away by the machines
after he defeats agent Smith and reboots
the matrix there are a number of ways
the film could explain Neos return the
most obvious of which is by telling us
that he didn't really die after all and
that the machines ultimately nursed him
back to health
then there's the explanation that
because of his status as the one neo was
always at least partially a software
creation the product of programming
mixing with biology
perhaps the software in him survived and
reincarnated in the new matrix whatever
the case we can't wait to see how we get
him back but now yeah I'm taking on back
neo is the one so there are all kinds of
possibilities to which that character
could return from the dead but how
exactly will carrie-anne moss return is
Trinity her character is quite clearly
dead after being impaled on machinery at
the end of the Matrix Revolutions
she's an amazing warrior but she's not
the one thankfully the sci-fi realm of
this franchise offers plenty of
possibilities for her return as well
humans aren't born so much as they're
grown which leaves the door open for
genetic engineering cloning and all
manner of other things perhaps Trinity
was replicated there's also the
possibility that Trinity now only exists
as software a program within the matrix
conceived to replace her physical self
made from preserved data about her
personality and appearance however it
happens her return could ultimately be
even more fascinating than Neos while
neo and Trinity journey to the Machine
City to put an end to the war in the
Matrix Revolutions Morpheus stays behind
to help with the final battle at Zion
arriving at the last minute so link
could activate an EMP that effectively
pauses the battle so the humans can
prepare for their last stand when neo
reaches the truce with the machines
Morpheus is among the survivors of Zion
one of the
last surviving leaders of the free human
race Laurence Fishburne who played
Morpheus in the original Matrix trilogy
was notably absent from the list of
names attached to the new film that
doesn't necessarily mean he won't be in
the movie but in the event Fishburne's
not around then what happened to
Morpheus does the story just not concern
him will he be played by a different
actor he's too big a presence in the
franchise for the film to ignore so we
can't wait to see how the matrix 4
explains what happened to everybody's
favorite freedom fighter
The Matrix Reloaded and the Matrix
Revolutions established that the matrix
is full of rogue programs some of these
are from much older versions of the
matrix and they have their own agendas
plans and seemingly supernatural
abilities the Oracle tells neo that
these are the source of humanity stories
about vampires werewolves and other
creatures as the program's basically do
as they please after refusing deletion
when the matrix rebooted at the end of
revolutions we saw that both the Oracle
and the architect were still present but
what about the rogue programs is the
Merovingian still scheming with the next
version of the simulation is the
trainman
what other rogue programs might have
resisted to leash on the last time
around and are operating now it'll be
interesting indeed to see the state of
rogue programs in the new version of
this world and the Matrix Reloaded neo
meets a character called Sarah a program
serving and protecting the Oracle the
guy acts as an Authenticator for
visitors by fighting them before they
can see her it's eventually made clear
that Sarah is unusual even by the
standards of other programs with strange
abilities when neo looks at him through
the matrixes code he sees a golden
burning light while everything else
around Seraph is green at one point one
of the Merovingians thugs refers to him
as wingless in the multiplayer game the
matrix online it's revealed that Sarah
once acted as an agent in the first
version of the matrix the paradise
version making him something akin to an
angel serifs angel status makes him
apparently second only to neo in terms
of fighting ability and his status as a
product of the first matrix makes him
one of the oldest programs in existence
so will he show up in the matrix for
he's a fascinating character and it
would be great to see the next film
return him as a key part of the mythos
at the end of revolutions neo manages to
negotiate a peace between the machines
and humans human civilization would be
allowed to continue
some form and humans would have a chance
to leave the matrix up front so what
does human civilization look like now
it'll be interesting to see what's
changed is ion still the only human city
have humans found a way to survive on
the surface with the machines heavy
pollution are there more people the
biggest question is whether the piece
lasted and if so for how long just how
long do you think this piece is going to
the nest
the architect took a cynical view of
things so it's quite possible that he
began at that very moment to explore new
ways to subjugate and undermine
humanity's future as supposedly free and
since so much of the thematic weights of
the matrix is already tied up in themes
of determinism versus free will it's
easy to see how that cycle would begin
again it's also possible that humans
have used their newfound ability to
leave the matrix and begin a kind of
cold war with the machines with the hope
of wiping them out entirely if you're
the type of fan who likes to pick apart
the world established in the matrix you
may have arrived at a lingering question
why wouldn't the machines have adopted
alternative means of energy rather than
just farming humans after the peace
established in the Matrix Revolutions
it's a question that has to come up
again with humans now granted the
freedom to choose to leave the matrix or
not as the result of neo sacrifice how
have the machines adapted to their new
coexistence have they adopted
alternative means of energy if humanity
changed then the machines likely had to
do some kind of adjusting as well and
that will be quite an interesting idea
for the matrix for to explore where a
neo had to be dragged out of the matrix
after some convincing by Morpheus humans
will now be given an upfront decision
they can leave the simulated universe
they know for a free and real life in a
harsher world or they can stay in the
matrix with all its simulated modern
comfort higness is bliss as the original
trilogy made clear there were some who
will choose to forget about the real
world and simply carry on living in the
matrix with modern conveniences while
others will choose reality now that
everyone gets to make that choice the
big question is what will that choice
look like how do the machines present
their arguments to both sides try to
convince souls in the matrix to stay or
go if you're born outside of the matrix
can you try it and see if you'd like to
stay the film reportedly starts
production in early 2020 so
it won't be too long before we find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]